you were smart to do smoking the band
I'll tell you why and I think this was
your thinking tell me if I'm right
Sybil everyone thought oh she's crazy
and you really kind of for lack of a
better term
ugh lead yourself oh right the thought
behind doing Smokey and the Bandit is
hey okay Burt Reynolds is in the
number-one movie star but you play a hot
chick so that was the plan right yes it
was kind of I did kind of think well
maybe I should do it cuz there wasn't a
script and I didn't know bird and just
call just said let's just live our way
through this thing
do you like Smokey and the Bandit I
haven't seen in quite some time
hi how did you feel about it when you
did it I just thought it was the end of
everything that I had worked so hard to
do good night but it was shocking why
did you take it then just because of the
the because I just there's there's just
a part of me that something was I
respond to they go that I think okay
let's just jump off this cliff
it wasn't careful it wasn't carefully
thought out and I just thought it was
film it wasn't Sybil had been television
it thrust me back on the screen in film
it had taken me so long to get to film
and it was with Burt who was you know a
huge star he was so you know charming
and funny I just there was a little
kernel of me that thought maybe we could
pull something off also how need him the
director the director was the
world-class stunt coordinator hadn't
really made a film but if anyone could
just do and it was just that's all he
did was figure out how to make those
stunts work have the people be safe and
hasn't be funny but when you get to a
movie set and there's hardly a script
and Bert's winging it and they say just
say whatever comes into your mind we'll
fix it later I think you would go
berserk well you don't you don't say fix
it later it really is in it becomes in
the lap of the actors I mean that under
this circumstances because we would just
drive off are you credited as a writer
in that film no you kind of should be
shouldn't you since you're kind of like
sitting there making up a dialogue but
but we all did you know that's there are
many films there's many times in film
you do stuff like that and Jackie
Gleason was in that now I idolized
Jackie Gleason like everyone does is
there real kismet there between you and
him or you know I didn't I didn't really
work with him so I didn't know him very
well I mean we would when when we would
make that transitional point where one
car would pull up and the occupants
would leave so Burt and I would leave
and there would be Jackie sitting in his
chair getting ready to get into his
vehicle and off they'd go so there was a
moment of interchange but not much yeah
but everybody you know just worshipped
him and sort of were like sitting at his
feet yeah and and he just he was
wonderful to be around he didn't
there wasn't any prima donna sort of
part of him at all do you worry about
box office like do you care about the
box office gross on Doris or do you kid
you care when Norma Rae came out I mean
I bet you even when Norma Rae came out
which was right after Smokey and the
Bandit thank God because that all of a
sudden made you the serious actress
again right you could have gone down a
whole nother road were they afraid to
now put you in Norma Rae because you had
done smokey in the Bandit the answer the
question is I didn't have to there was
the one thing you know that I wanted to
do that I didn't have to fight for they
wanted you they did not want me but
Marty Rick wanted me the director and he
said they don't want you they want do
you know they wanted everybody else and
no one could envision Norma Rae Sally
Field no not at all and so they'd asked
all the other actresses at the time who
were you know the bankable or the who
were the big ones Jane Fonda I think was
Jill Clayburgh and it was Marsha Mason
and it was you know there was a whole
bevy of them they asked every one of
them and they all luckily turned it down
why do you think they turned it down
they probably thought it wasn't going to
be a big box office success really I
don't I really don't know that sour you
on a project when you hear everyone in
Hollywood has turned it down do you say
oh you know maybe there's something they
see that I don't know not when it's
something that's written is exquisitely
as this was so
no it would it meant it was meant to be
that I somehow was meant to do this I
said I don't the studio doesn't want you
but if you want to do it I will fight
for you and and I will win and he did
when you won the Oscar those ladies must
have been kicking themselves in that
hose up against you when you do you
remember I think it was Bette Midler was
in the role was in the Rose Marsha Mason
Marsha Mason chapter two Jill Clayburgh
in Jane and Jane Fonda did China
Syndrome oh my god so was all of them
Jill Clayburgh gets starting over yeah
and you're up against them do you think
you're gonna win after doing Norma do
you say I'm gonna win this no you don't
I you just don't think like that
I I don't do you prepare a speech I
didn't yeah but it was also a very
different era
you also don't you know they don't give
you clothes that are made by the finest
designers they don't yelling at you who
you wearing they're not none of that you
it's all about the department store and
get a dress right it wasn't the same
kind of whoop-dee-doo but is it fun for
you as a woman
as a girl to put on a fancy dress get
all dolled up and go to this big party
and then you win did they have all these
after parties where everyone's just sort
of at your feet in those days they
didn't have a lot of after parties
didn't have all of them it was one party
which was at Wolfgang Puck's Spago which
was in the middle of Hollywood but by
the time you do all the press you had to
do you know press up to press after
you've won and I ran to this to this
party afterward because I wanted to go
to the party - I just want to wanna be a
part of the body and everybody was sort
of leaving it was the party was over it
was like can I have a piece of pizza
yeah where's my congratulations